>>Female Announcer: Joining us all the way
from Santa Cruz to talk about his latest book.
Uh, his book is called "The Misleading Mind:
How We Create Our Own Problems and How Buddhist
Psychology Can Help Us Solve Them" So Karuna's
going to talk a little about this today. And
a little bit of background before he gets
started. So Karuna, uh, spent twelve years
working with Tibetan refugees in Nepal and
studying the Buddhist masters in person live.
Ah, his Karuna Group Practice supplies the
Buddhist psychology to people and organizations.
Karuna's also a senior trainer for the Potential
Project. This is a corporate based mindfulness
training. And you can read more about it at
www.potentialproject.com. And essentially
what we're covering today is to talk about
the process for working with rather than against
depression, anxiety or compulsions by recognizing
habitual ways that our minds often can mislead
us. So very excited to have Karuna here today
and again, thanks for coming. Please welcome
Karuna. And I'll hand over mic.
>>Karuna: Thank you.
[Applause]
>>Karuna: Is this on? Hope I don't trip on
the wires. Well first I'm very honored to
be here. They told me I have to stand close
to this podium, but I'm going to try and creep
around a bit as time goes on. I'm very honored
to be here. Thank you for coming. And, you
know, I don't know if anyone's, has anyone
else written a book before? No, yeah? Did
you think someone would read it? Yeah. I mean
while writing the book I thought I'll write
this book and it's quite a labor of love.
I never thought that actually anyone would,
the reading part, the audience part never
came alive until I was finished and then I
realized I had to do a lot more work around
it. But I'm very, uh very, very happy to have
written this book and very happy that people
are reading it and it seems to be of some
use to them. Um, usually when I give these
kind of talks I think it's really important
to set up the context, right, because the
words in the book come from somewhere, right,
it's all interdependent on what where I came
from and. I think that's important to share
that. Usually start my history around the
time um, I finished High School. Uh, I didn't,
I wasn't much of a student. Didn't like school
that much. And so I took a year off and my
mother said 'if you're going to take the year
off' after I graduated from high school she
said "You have to promise me you'll go to
college in a year." And so I promised her,
and of course the year ended and I said I
think I'm going to take another year. And
uh, she was quite firm and said 'you know
you made your promise'. So she was very kind
in that she found a school up in the Lincoln
Washington that people won't know about now,
but it, back this is the ear- late, early
seventies, where there weren't a lot of alternative
options for schools, colleges. But there was
one in Santa Cruz, UC Santa Cruz was just
beginning I think. So I went to Evergreen
State College, which allowed you to study
and graduate without actually having to take
grades. So you had evaluations, it was perfect
for me. But the reason I tell you this is,
um, I had begun to get interested in, I grew
up outside Los Angeles, part of the whole
end of the middle of the hippie thing. And,
um, I was somehow got interested in yoga,
as a high school student and I went to a yoga
retreat. And, uh, prior to that I was, of
course, doing all the things that we did then,
you know, doing lots of partying, drugs, the
whole thing and went to this, uh, yoga retreat.
And I came back and I gave up eating meat,
smoking cigarettes and getting high all that.
So I lost all my friends. No one came around
anymore. I thought my friends were my friends,
but I guess they were, you know, but they
weren't. Except for one guy Dave, and Dave
is featured in the book, in the early part
of the book. So, that was quite a wakeup call
and there wasn't much, it was really hard
to find something. I was really interested
in meditation, what is meditation? And it
wasn't easy to find much explained in those,
then. Um, so I ended up at Evergreen State
College I was still involved in yoga. And
then uh a program came along called the Year
In Nepal. And I don't know if you know, if
you read, you know thing the interesting thing
in those days was, you know, find your guru.
People were going to India and finding a guru
and I had a little bit of that sort of resonating
with, well not a little and really resonated
with me. But here I was stuck in this college
and I thought "A year in Nepal. Where's that
at?" I didn't know where Nepal was. Looked
on the map and of course, as you know, I'm
sure everyone knows it's right next to India.
So I thought, well that's easy, I'll sneak
into India find some guru, I'll do, you know,
get this degree and everything will be cool.
Well I loved Nepal and has anyone here been
in Nepal? No? Well it's changed a lot but
it's still a beautiful country, worthwhile
to go visit. And uh I was there, I went to
Nepal in 1975. And instead of staying a year
I left in 1988. I did have one, a year and
a half break in the early stages back here
where I had to come back and start a master's
program. Because the only way you could stay
in Nepal then was either you had to be in
development work or a student. So I knew I
had to do the student thing. So I went back
and I did the longest master's degree of anyone
ever. It was like ten years, so I could keep
my visa. Thanks. So that's the really core
part of this book is that the foundation of
it of course, was the ten twelve years I spent
in Nepal and I found myself, uh, really, originally
I went there to study the difference between
Hinduism that was arriving in America comparing
to what really exists in a Hindu country.
And Nepal is sort of Hindu and Buddhist. But
that's a little bit like someone going to
Silicon Valley to study technology, you know.
It's like it's just imbued here, right. It's
it's, how do you extract it out? So I became
pretty bored and disillusioned, but there
was a monastery nearby of the village I was
living. I was immersed in Nepalese culture,
Nepalese language. There was a monastery teaching,
uh, meditation course for westerns. For foreigners.
And it, again this is 1975, it was very tough
if you were interested in, you'd see Tibetan
Buddhists walking around and you really wonder
what were they about and you could. But to
study it, it almost, it was very tough, but
there was this monastery there that taught
these one month cour- intensive courses in
English, Kopan monastery. That's where I ended
up. I didn't want to go there because I was,
it wasn't cool enough for me. Because I was
like Nepalese guy. And I didn't want to go
up there with a bunch of foreigners and tourists.
So I did swallow my pride, fortunately, went
up there. And it was at this one month course
and then that's where I stayed for the next
twelve years or so. Very unique place. What
was unique about it, it featured, was unique
about it- one of their Lama named Lama Thubten
Yeshe who passed away in 1984. And uh, you
know, again, I had the great fortune of working
closely with him. He was, what I would call
a renaissance lama. Gotta get away from that.
Um, what I mean by that is that he, um, I
don't know he had this wisdom and understanding
that things were changing really fast. That
Tibetans had been of course, expelled from
Tibet, many of them, hundred thousand of them
or so. And he had seen the writing on the
wall. We were the first monastery to start
an English program, a western studies, a modern
studies program, which I was responsible for,
which was kind of ironic, 'cause I hated school.
So here I was starting something for them,
the young monks. There were about 85 monks
in those days. And so, uh, but he said to
me, you know, and he said, he had a program,
he had a way of thinking, where he said, and
this really the mission of this book. If I
get anything across today, here's what I want
to get across. The ideas that we're talking
about in Buddhist thought are universal. You
do not have to be Buddhist. You can be Christian,
you can be Jewish, you can be American, or
you can be Russian, you can be, it doesn't
matter. Now there is a, there is a challenge
in the translation, right? Because these ideas
are still new in modern language, in modern
cultures. So the really the mission of this
book, was really lama Yeshe's mission. So
I feel I was just carrying the mantel and
doing my little part for him. Uh, in that,
I really really want to explain these things.
Now I had the great fortune of being there
a long time studying, I still study, that
was 1975 till now. And I, it's just not possible
for everyone to do that. So, I hope that,
uh, through this message of this book that
you're able to sort of jump time and all that
effort, uh, to get to some of these ideas.
Now the, Lama Yeshe's couple of things he
said, one of the things he said to me and
to other students, he said "You know these
ideas are universal. You have to cut through
them." I think once we, a group of us, uh,
asked the Dalai Lama did he think Tibetan
Buddhism, um, uh, able to transfer into modern
culture, or into the West and those who said
it then. And he said "Well, leave the Tibetan
with us and take the Buddhism." And I think
that's, so it's tricky to find to extract
the culture from what is the actual principles.
The principles for the most part in Buddhist
thought are psychological. You know, it of
course, there is the philosophy. It's really
not, it's religious depending on the culture
that it traveled to. So there was the historical
Buddha, Shakyamuni Buddha alive more than
2500 years ago. Which is really fascinating,
a little village, some little area of India
then. And it, you know it's really amazing
it spread from, uh, as far south as Sri Lanka
as far north as southern Russia as far east
as, uh, Indonesia and Korea, Japan, north,
I mean china, and south east Asia and as far
west as, I think as, well as far west we know
for sure as Afghanistan. And where ever it
went it didn't ask the cultures to adapt to
that system of thought, right? It said "What,
in our system, in this system of thought is
applicable to your culture?" So think about
what's happening now today in our culture.
And that's a hard word to say, our culture,
'cause if I just talk about America it's,
uh, a multiple cultures, right? But if we
just generically, or generally, uh, what do
you think is the system of the dominate system
of thought in this modern culture? Does anyone
want to say?
>>Male #1: Our culture? Scientific [inaudible].
>>Karuna: Yeah, thank you, exactly, right.
Now isn't it amazing, scientific, and materialism
and it, and you know, see in Buddhist system
of thought there is a science that can morph
and adapt in here into this culture. As the
[unintelligible] dalai lama for many years
had a dialog with modern western day uh, modern
day scientists. So, that's the idea and I
think that from my background, uh, when I
um, those years in Nepal what was I going
to do when I came back to the States? You
know, how do you integrate that? I mean, how
do you integrate that that richness of experience
and that's why I became a, um, psychotherapist.
I got my master's in clinical psychology.
And it was tough, because, uh, I had already
studied this complete system of thought. Very
complete 2500 years old, it had been debated,
it had been, you know, uh, uh, discussed,
it been meditated upon, it's you know. All
this so rich so deep, so thick. And then I
come back to California and I'm working with,
you know, getting a master's degree psychology
which is a system of thought. It's really,
really new. Isn't it? Think about it. It's,
it's, it's very new. And, um, so my job and
it was difficult, my job still is. Is how
do we integrate these ideas? So then Lama
Yeshe said, he said to me, he said "You know
you need to communicate these ideas so that
your mother can understand them." Ok. So they're
not meant to be just for the scholar. And
that's that's a pretty that's a big task because,
I don't know about your mother but, you know,
it's not easy to do. So that's the idea, is
to communicate them so that anyone can understand
them, because they are useful. Let's go to
another part of this.
Uh why is this even interesting? Why even
get involved in this Buddhist psychology?
Uh, there's only really one purpose and that
is that, uh, the we all are looking for the
same thing. What we're looking for is, it's
pretty simple, is to be happy. And we could
make an argument that everything we do is
for that purpose. And it becomes really fascinating,
of course then we have to define what do you
mean by happiness? But, the other thing about
Buddhist thought is that we define everything,
well, all important terms are defined. So
that we have the same, uh, language, to have
a conversation with. You know, um, I'm just
curious has anyone studied, you know, excuse
me, studied psychology in here? Did you, so
psychology. Psych means what?
>>Female #1: Soul
>>Karuna: Soul, what else? Soul, psyche
>>Male #2: Mind
>>Karuna: Mind, And -ology?
>>Audience: Study of.
>>Karuna: Study of! Study of the mind, right?
Did you ever study the mind, have a class
on the definition, the nature of mind in your
study of psychology? No. Anybody else. In
Russia did they? No. Anybody else? Is there
a third hand? I was thinking there was a third,
but you chickened out. Um, isn't that amazing?
I mean think about that. Here we are trained
to be psychologists, ok, psychotherapists,
therapists of the mind and we don't have a
working accepted definition of the mind. I
don't think there's any other, I don't know
if there's any other discipline that you would
have that same situation. If you were to travel
throughout the Buddhist world I can't say
about, you know, the sort of, I mean, at least
if you'd ask a scholar in, a Buddhist scholar
in Japan, a Buddhist scholar wherever, in
Tibet. If you have a Buddhist scholar in Sri
Lanka, southeast Asia, generally speaking
they will come up with the same definition
of the mind. It's debated in terms of what
that means, but you have a working definition.
There's not an argument. I think that's fascinating.
Here in the western world we don't have that.
I think that's interesting, I think that's
kind of strange. Ok. So the purpose in Buddhist
psychology what is why is it psychology? Why
even talk about it? I don't think there is
Islamic psychology, or Judaic, Christian psychology
that I know. Why Buddhist psychology? Isn't
that kind of weird? The reason is simple.
The reason is that this whole purpose of all
these systems of thought really is to be happy,
right? To give you a system of thought to
kind of liberate yourself from difficulties
from problems. So, the Buddhist approach,
what I think is very, very unique, is it's
inner approach. That to, in fact the Tibetan
word for Buddhist is a word called nangpa
and "nang" means inside or inner. And "pa"
is, uh, is a marker for a person or being.
So it means "inner being." It's interesting.
An inner being is the definition of Buddhist.
So you don't have to be, if anyone here who
thinks of themselves as the inner being you're
Buddhist, so you don't have to worry about
changing religion. Ok? The thing is, and we
don't want you to anyway. You're, um, the
the, so really I think again Buddhism is more
of the [unintelligible] dalai calls it mind
science, why? Mind science is a synonym for
psychology, isn't it? Close enough. Ok. So
again mind science. So I urge, uh, I you know
the, within this book, my point is that I
think people can understand. I don't think
I was too shallow or superficial in the book.
I really wanted to get you know, deeper into
the concepts as best I could without losing
my audience. Because we're, you know, we can
really lose it pretty easily. Um, so some
of the ideas here are that number one the
only purpose of Buddhist psychology is to
be happy. And in the Buddhist psychology the
idea is that happiness, ok you all know this,
but just to rephrase it, happiness doesn't
come from outside. Ok, there's only two places,
there's the outside and the inside, there's
subject, there's the object, right? And yet,
we spend all of our time, most of our time,
maybe not consciously, maybe not you know
intentionally, but if we think about, you
know, to be happy, we are generally speaking,
going to look for something to help us on
the outside. Not always, but generally, that's
our sort of default mode. That's because that's
the way we're trained. You know I think it'd
be good to start training you know, kids and
people that know that there's options and
so in this context, happiness in the Buddhist
context means a balanced mind. Ok. happiness
is an inside job. Ok, so uh, if happiness
is an inside job then we need to understand
psychology. But we need to understand our
psychology. The idea is not to necessarily
understand all these fabulous theories, which
we have tons of. You know that in what the
Buddha taught himself, I was reading the other
day, back 2500, 2600 years ago, sometimes
the monks in the monasteries recite the, what
we call the sutras, which are just the words
and not the commentaries, just the words that
Buddha spoke. And someone was saying I read
something the other day it would take a monk
of course depends how fast he reads, right?
Take him forty days to recite the entire sutras,
that Buddha spoke. That's a lot of words.
Buddha taught for forty years, unfortunately
you know and with our other great teachers,
they maybe didn't teach as long, right? In
forty years he didn't teach different things
every teaching, he kept repeating what he
was teaching. Whatever. So I have a question,
so can someone, um, just look at your hand
for a second, everybody has to do this, right?
People eating don't have to do this. Ok can
someone tell me what color it is? What color
is your hand?
[chatter]
>>Male #2: I would say it's a mixture of colors.
>>Karuna: Mixture of colors, generally what
would you say?
>>Male #2: Mine's pink.
>>Karuna: Pink. Tan. Tan. No one's white,
but that's interesting. Ok someone tell me
what's the texture of your hand? Huh?
>>Female #2: Soft?
>>Karuna: Soft, ok, what else? What's it's
shape? This is not hard, is it?
[chuckle]
>>Karuna: You got shape, shape is I don't
know how you describe the shape but you've
got five digits, finger things. Ok, what's
it composed of? Skin. What else?
[chatter]
>>Karuna: Right, right, ok so, we've had,
there's more we could talk about the hand
right? There's more uh, to talk about the
hand, but enough. Isn't it interesting we
are pretty, we're pretty good. Now we've had
this hand since the moment we're born, at
least, I mean it formed in the womb as well.
Now can someone tell me what is the color
of your mind?
>>Female #3: Rainbow.
>>Karuna: Grey [chuckle] I'll go with that,
I'm not sure what else. What is the shape
of your mind?
Ok, what's it composed of? Or constructed
of? Ok, so we've had the mind since the day
we were born also, maybe before. We don't
know the mind. We know our hand. You know
if I asked you to describe your car, you'd
probably do as good a job as with your hand.
If I asked you to desc- whatever. Everyone
knows how their face looks, we look at it
every morning in the mirror or whatever. But
isn't it weird that at least half of our being,
maybe more, but at least half of it is a mind,
right? You got mind and body. That's kind
of strange. Don't you think it's strange?
Who thinks it's strange? That we don't know
what the nature of a mind is. Yeah. If we
know the nature of our mind, then we are able
to actually, uh, take a hold of our own happiness.
In general what it's considered in Buddhist
psychology is that the mind is the key to
being happy. And happy you can define however
you want, I don't care how you define it really.
It means, what, it means kind
of contentment, uh, ease, clarity, um, stability,
those are all things we don't have, I don't
think. If you're like me, maybe you're not,
if you're like me, we don't have those things,
ok. In general, our minds are up and down
up and down up and down and we're not very
clear, most of us are not very clear. And
most of us don't even know what the mind is.
And those of us who have studied who are sort
of involved in psychology at least we should
know. It's kind of like being a hand surgeon
without knowing the nature of a hand. Ok.
Oh, I just for the fun of it, I looked, I
tried to find out how many studies have done
on mollusks. Don't ask me why mollusks, I
just, it was random. I couldn't find how many
studies were done--. I googled it. Ok, and
I couldn't find how many I googled, you know,
uh, mollusks. I didn't find out how many studies
were done, maybe if someone can ever find
out I'd like to know. But I did find out there's
75000 kinds of mollusks. I thought that was
amazing. I mean someone has counted that or
figured that out. Anyway the point was, what
I did do I did do a search on uh, the hand.
And I know it's not scientific, but uh, if
3 billion, I got 3 billion different sites
that I could go to that were associated with
the hand. And but with the hand there were
only 2 billion. I think that is interesting.
Um, I think the mind's more important, well
that's a value judgment. I should say it's
more important. So the mind, but I want to
quote un Lama Yeshe. He says "The human mind
has both positive and negative sides, but
the negative is transient, very temporary,
your up and down emotions are like clouds
in the sky. Beyond them the real basic human
nature is clear and pure."
That's pretty cool. Ok. Beyond them the human
nature is clear and pure. This is because
you know I know that a lot of times when we
look at Buddhist thought and Buddhist psychology,
there's a lot of talk about suffering, right?
Yeah? The reason for that is not because that's
all there is the reason for that is that we
don't understand how things are and it's only
by understanding the problem that we can actualize
the solution. So you know sometimes it's a
little bit, uh, Buddhist therapy so to speak,
it's a little bit intense because it um, it's
it does force us to deal with our stuff. It
really does. So it's not for everybody, ok?
What I mean by that, is in the book, I get
often asked, what did I mean by problems become
friends? Because that's in the book. And it's
a little tricky thing to understand, it can
be tricky or not be tricky and I'll tell you
why. For somebody who is a 'spiritual practitioner'
that idea is not difficult, that problems
could be your friends. Now what do I mean
by spiritual practitioner? I have a very specific
meaning about that. I think a spiritual practitioner
is anybody who is interested in and focused
upon developing one's inner potential. Ok,
so I don't mean anything religious by spiritual.
Because religions are religions. You could
be a religious person and not be spiritual,
in my book. Ok? And you could you non-religious
and be very spiritual and you be involved
in therapy, right? Therapy or coaching and
be very spiritual because you are really trying
to figure out, you know, you're trying to
learn. To be a spiritual person means to learn
about how we work internally. That's what
I think. And access in learning the correct
stuff too, right? There's a lot of ideas out
there, I mean, their helpful, but maybe not
helpful in the very long term. So if you are
engaged in or are interested in uh, developing
and believe there's a inner potential that
we're not accessing and you're interested
in that and you're pursuing it, then in my
book you're a spiritual person. And for the
sake of uh, to get this out now, I mean, uh,
I we do a lot of work around people in work,
businesses things like that. Why? This is
where we live. So does it mean you can't be
a spiritual person when you are at work? No.
We believe as we get better, it's a , that's
why we call ourselves, you know, you're a
practitioner, is that you have to practice
this. So it's like why are problems our friends?
Because it's only through problems that the
crap comes up. That's a generalization, ok,
but generally speaking, it's, in relationship,
first of all with other people, a lot of the
times, we get upset, we get jealous, we get
anxious, we get tired, we get impatient, we
become sad. All these things mostly by the
way, in relation to other people and when
they're not in relation to other people, they'll,
those are our problems. So, my definition
of happiness, now has changed over the years,
it keeps changing actually. Uh, meaning, it
gets sort of more refined, I should say. It
used to be, I remember my, one of my son years
ago asked me he said "Dad why don't you get
stoned anymore? Why don't you smoke dope anymore?"
And I said "Because it doesn't make me feel
better anymore." Right? So, it's kind of,
the bar changes and as the bar changes, that's
where you aim for. Ethics. Another good question.
Ethics are not in my opinion are something
that should imposed from above, or morality.
Ethics are something that work for you. So
in terms of Buddhist ethics we don't certain
things only because they disturb the mind
of myself and others. And what did I say the
opposite of happiness is? A disturbed mind.
Ok? So because of very simple and very pragmatic
you don't, we don't, have to change all this
stuff. Just do it slowly, like that's why
I have no moral qualms with getting stoned,
it's not a moral thing. It has to deal with
it makes my happiness lower and I want to
be happy just like everybody else. Ok? Not
everyone has that that's not their reality.
That's my situation, ok? So it's just like
that. That's what ethics are. Ok, for lack
of a better in case you're interested. I wasn't
going to go into that. Um, another thing Buddha
said, he said, uh, he said "Everything has
mind in the lead, has mind in the forefront,
is made by mind." Wow. I mean, if that's true,
we have to research it, see if it's true.
We're focusing on the wrong things, in order
to be happy. So in order to be happy, of course,
you go to work, it's not to be happy. You
turn your work into happiness. You turn your
work into your spiritual path. That's my point.
I'm sorry, I lost my thread a little bit.
Work and spirituality are interconnected,
it's up to you. If you use work, if you use
your relationship with your partner, if you
use your relationship with your kids, if you
use your relationship with the traffic out
there as a means to further develop yourself
internally, work is a spiritual path. Ok.
And, we all want to do that anyway, because
we do want to be happy and the mind is the
source of happiness. And the way we do it
by just to give you the final equation on
that is when things arise, like uh, you know,
anxiety because you have to turn in, you know,
a project you've been working on and you've
got to present it in front of your team and
your boss and it's like anxiety and it's like.
What happ- that is an opportunity to become
more spiritually developed, because you can
you can look, you know, you can like do those
things about becoming calm or positive reinforcement,
or have a beer, or whatever you do, right?
That's the outer approach. That's not the
spiritual approach. The spiritual approach
is, the problem I'm having in this presentation
is within me, it's my anxiety. It's my lack
of confidence, ok? So it's a mental construct,
right? It's a mental so the only thing that
will really work to get rid of it long term
is a mental approach. That's a spiritual person,
ok? It's also psychologically sound. It works.
We become psychologically more healthy. Now
in the book I can't go into all the techniques,
there's thousands of techniques we could talk
about, ok? And it's not really opportunity
to but, main thing first thing we have to
do- How much time do I got? I do, I do want
to share this, because I know people always
want techniques and tips. And um, and un that
that what we need to do as a first--, I think
I offered four steps, one four step method
in the book that talks about the first thing
we need to do is be aware that we have a choice.
And generally speaking if you're like me,
we are in automatic pilot mode, right? We
are not very conscious, we are not very aware,
we are not very mindful. If you're like me.
And the beauty of this human life is that
we do have a choice to be mindful. And you
don't, if we just just make that decision
it's like wow, this moment right now becomes
extremely valuable and precious. And when
we don't do that, we just carry on as usual
and then we die. Ok?
[Laughter]
>>Karuna: Don't mean to sound dramatic, but
that is what happens. So so the first thing
is to really go hey, wow, I have this beautiful,
beautiful opportunity precious life. Sure
there is problems, I'm not talking about,
there are problems that's the nature of life.
That's why Buddhism is kind of negative. It's
not that its negative, it just says that things
are kind of negative. Problems don't go away
on their own. We're problem free today and
then we have problems tomorrow, it's amazing.
And we have no control over it, the external
stuff. And we try to control it, right? It's
very very fascinating and it's a great topic
to discuss how we try to control suffering
on the outside. Doesn't mean we should stop
doing those things by the way. We should try,
but we have to be conscious of our intentions,
you know. So, um, and then they don't really
help the solution is something internal, ok?
So the first step is just go I have a choice
of how this, how I am in this minute, in this
moment, in this experience. If you're in traffic
and you're pissed off on the Bay Bridge, you
have a choice, ok? When you go out to the
lunch area and you're really excited because
yesterday they had what they have yesterday?
What was the special? Huh?
>>Female #3: Mexican.
>>Karuna: Mexican! And you go, gosh I really,
fish tacos, yeah, so you go, I really look
forward to those fish tacos. They actually
have them again today because people loved
them yesterday and you go out there and they're
all gone. What happens in the mind? The more
you thought about it from yesterday the more
agitated the mind becomes. If you thought
about it, just how quickly the mind gets to
agitated, ok? So then you start yelling for
them "Where's the fish tacos, is there anymore
in the back?" Yeah, you know, like that.
[Laughter]
>>Karuna: And because we have this default
mode that that's, there isn't anything wrong
with having the fish tacos, but you see, we're
mislead. Misleading mind, ok, got that out
there. We're mislead to think that's going
to make me happy and no one would say "Oh
a fish taco's going to make me happy, what
are you talking about?" I'm talking about
different understanding of the word happiness.
Because in that moment we're not making the
choice to be different. We are on autopilot,
ok? We have a choice. Ok?
Second step is, if I could find it. Oh, it's
I talk about is setting up the laboratory.
So ever- a lot of people know about my influence
practice up there. Once you recognize that
you have a choice, it sort of a create a gap
and you can just go to the breath. Ok, breath
is always with us. And it, again, I I don't
have the time, but there's a technique, you
know, we call it the A-B-C technique where
you just check the tension in your body, that's
anatomy for A, A for Anatomy, B is for breath
so you just connect with your breath in the
nostrils or your stomach. Don't change it
just it is what it is and it's on the fish
tacos, you just found out and your breaths
going [inhales] like that, you just watch
it, ok? And then the C stands for counting.
Just count the in and exhalation ok? When
you go one if you could do up to ten and then
you turn it around and you go back to one,
ok? This is again just a little more solid
technique and then uh, that's just this uh,
four steps, you get the mind a little bit
out of its reactive mode. Ok? The third is
uh, you know you look at what's going on.
This is powerful is that you just identify
your emotion, ok? And in Buddha psychology
the problems we have are really related to
uh, we have these afflicted, or disturbing
emotions. And there what's run the show, we're
not in control of the mind, the mind is in
control of us. That is not, that's not right.
We should be in control of the mind, not the
afflicted disturbing emotions. Ok? You know,
if you really think about it, there is nothing
much preventing us in the next minute of being
in total fear, or totally taken over by rage,
or totally taken over by jealousy. It doesn't
take much, it happens like that. And once
you're in it, it's like a virus, right, it's
hard to get rid of. Ok? This is what we're
talking about, this is what we're saying,
we don't have to be that way. There is, we
can actually live this life where we're in
control. Now and, it's not easy. It takes
time, lot of time and by the way, you get
better, you don't actually, when you're fully
healed, you're like you know those, like the
dalai Lama. So let's not, you know, can't
get too unrealistic. We can get there and
I would say in my lot of years of doing this,
35 or whatever years I am a better, I'm better.
Not there yet, but I'm better, no doubt. Ok?
So and I think my friends are and people who
try to, so, um, but that so that's the second
the third step. It's like identify what emotions
are arising, because when you name it, what
happens when you name it, is you objectify
it. When we objectify it, ok, when we don't
objectify, do you know like when you get if
you get like agitated or angry anxious, or
depressed it's very interesting psychological,
um, condition where we merge with the depression
don't we? We merge with the anger. It's like
I'm angry. When we say I'm angry, there's
no subject object. The linguistics of I'm
angry is subject object, isn't it? I is the
subject. We can see anger and I and we say
I am angry. But the conception is I merge
with it, I am one with anger. There's no way
I can say I'm angry if you merged. I mean,
I don't wanna go, it's-- Think about it. In
if you are it, you can't see yourself, ok?
So obviously you are not the anger, but we're
so confused. So we say I'm angry. For the
degree of subjectivity by the way, there's
more control. That's what we're looking for.
So we objectify the disturbing emotions and
by the way because I only have a short time,
there are positive emotions too. The job is
to uh, develop the positive emotions. Unfortunately
for some reason the negative afflictive do
run, are more powerful in this in the sense
that we're more habituate, but we all know
people who are compassionate right? WE all
know people who are wise, we all know people
who are kind, empathetic. Those are some of
the positive emotions. There are, but it gets,
the idea is, we got to rid the mind of those
ones that take over, which are anger, jealousy,
desire, confusion, things like that, anxiety.
Ok? Um, the fourth step is you take some action,
so you're there. And actions that you can
take when the afflictive minds are arising
are lots of different things, I can't give
you just one right here, um, I don't mean
to do that, uh, but there are a few in the
book or somewhere else. But the point is that
um, with action comes inquiry. Ok I want to
really stress that. I'm not, I really respect
the whole mindfulness movement is great. But
I think something is missing that we can add
to people. Once you develop a calm mind, it's
not a not, we can do more. And the thir- the
last, the more is inquiry. What I mean by
that is, uh, to inquire to the nature of what's
going on. So let's say you're getting really
angry. You know, you're really agitated, agitated.
So one of the things you can be, we have an
inquiry about, is how does that anger really
exist? You know how I was talking about subject
to object, if you just inquire about that,
what happens to the anger, does anyone know?
Dissipates. The inquiry itself is a powerful
antidote. Ok. And so when we inquire about
the nature of this, and then you can say,
oh, I'm angry. Well just like we did in the
beginning earlier about the mind, I am angry.
We say it all the time. What is that I? We
just take it for granted. But if you really
start looking for it, it's very interesting.
Very very interesting. And we have, by the
way, we have multiple I's, I's, I's. Multiple
I's, we are multi personality disordered.
Ok, I'm a father, I'm a husband, I'm a author,
I'm a therapist, I'm a coach, I'm angry, I'm
agitated, I'm nervous, I'm afraid, I mean
we've got it all through the day, right? Right?
So there's positive ones and there's more
negative ones. And I think that I think I
must be running out of time.
>>Female Announcer: You've got about two minutes.
>>Karuna: Two minutes, Oh! Questions! Ten
minutes for questions. Um, I really like questions,
I hope there's some questions. Uh-oh.
[Laughter]
>>Karuna: I'll just keep talking and I don't
want to do that. Yeah.
>>Male #3:: Uh, alright, I'm not sure what
to ask, alright I'll ask this question, what
would you define, it seems like you focus
more on Tibetan Buddhism. Right?
>>Karuna: Yes.
>>Male #3: [inaudible]
>>Karuna: Yes, Ok, so you were asking about
yeah, you were asking about uh that I speak
mainly from the Tibetan tradition which is
true and what is the difference or some differences
about the Tibetan tradition from other traditions.
>>Male #3: Yes, why are you more invested
more so in the Tibetan tradition?
>>Karuna: Ok why I am more invested in Tibetan
than in other traditions. Um, that's correct,
I'll answer the last part of the question
first, the reason is only because of luck.
I was in Nepal and the system of Buddhism
in Nepal it just so happens I, I found myself
living with Tibetan refugees. And that was
at Tibet, that monastery I mentioned to you,
Kopan Monastery was a Tibetan, it was it wasn't
only Tibetan, but the founders were Tibetan
refugees and so many of the monks were from
Tibetan families. Or in Nepal you have a lot
of tribes, a lot of tribes are really other
than political reasons their Tibetan. You
know, Sherpa's for example, Sherpa language
is a dialect of Tibet, we had a lot of Sherpa,
uh, um, Sherpa, um, monks. So so for me personally
was that's where I was. I tried to study all
a lot of the traditions, um, you know the
only, so I can only speak from that point
view. Now, in Buddhist approach there are
two primary, uh, traditions we could say.
But there, uh, one is the Theravada tradition
which is sometimes referred to as the southern
school. And the other is the Mahayana tradition
of which Tibetan Buddhism is part of, uh,
Buddhism in China, Korea, Japan, uh, Vietnam,
whereas Burma, and Thailand and Sri Lanka
are of the Theravada tradition. And so, for
me, um, it, the the Tibetan tradition offers
more philosophical ideas. For example people
refer to Tantra and Vasryana, that's something
very uh, linked with Tibetan tradition. So
it's it's just it's somewhat more extensive.
They're inclusive, by the way, the Mahayana
tradition, it includes the Theravada tradition.
You know and the teachings I should say. Yeah.
>>Female #4: Um I'm curious like at what point
with your study of Buddhism did you decide
to turn to a study of psychology. I was actually
a psychology/religion double major.
>>Karuna: Uh-huh.
>>Female #4: I was always trying to get to
that point like, where psychology was religion,
or took a lot of Buddhism classes. And like
the psychology of Buddhism. And like, was
there a defining moment or [inaudible]?
>>Karuna: Ah ha, so the question was uh, was
there a defining moment uh, when I uh, decided
to study psychology as opposed to religion?
Yeah. Um, well fortunately, I listened to
Lama Yeshe very carefully, I got the, got
it, that that Buddhist thought was about wasn't
really religious. There was religious parts,
but it's really a psychology and so I think
I studying psychology long before I came back
here and I was, I just loved it. I loved the
depth, uh, in Buddhist psychology, it's it's
very vast, I mean, just you know not to leave
you hanging it's not something interpretive.
It is a system of psychology, the mind is
explained, mental disorders are explained,
how experience arises, all it's very, very
vast and very, very in-depth, ah, the when
I came back here. I really wasn't I, I thought
I'd like western psychology but I found it
um, you know, I had I don't know what to say,
it's very useful in terms of applications,
like particularly in terms of crisis management.
Um, very useful in terms of helping us you
know, understanding how to communicate better
you know, Buddhist psychology doesn't really
go into that. Um, but as a theory, I didn't
find much as much use. So I don't know if
there was a defining moment, I think the defining
moment happened long before I came back. Studying
psychology here was really sort of a pragmatic
decision. Does that answer your question?
Yeah. Yeah
>>Female #5: So you talked about integrating
spirituality into work and your paths, so
how can anyone, you know watching you speak
whether you are at Google somewhere else,
um, integrate that or try to incorporate that
across a company?
>>Karuna: Oh yeah, uh, so, so Rachel was asking
how to integrate more around developing spiritual
approach to ones work, right? Throughout Google
we could just say. Um, Hah, um, have a conversation
with me about that? I mean, the, the there's
many things and I think the main thing is
develop a more mindful organization, ok.
>>Female #5: How do we do that as like a people
in the organization?
>>Karuna: Oh people in the organization how
do they do that? Well, um, you really need
instruction. The first thing is instruction,
uh, we offer, for example, I don't know if
I can promote, but we do offer a corporate
based mindfulness training program that is
designed for people in the workplace. That's
the beginning, the first thing is develop
a mindful approach, but I want to just make
my soapbox issue that it goes beyond that.
First my becoming a more mindful organization
through a training, I don't know who else
does that, but I'm sure there's other people.
But you need to have a program and our program
we work with organizations for eight, for
actually four months and develop people to
become their own trainers, which is one of
our strong beliefs. Also in my book and also,
my book, this idea that Lama Yeshe was very
strong was, he had this phrase you need to
become your own therapist. And that's what
my goal, I hope I can help people do that,
you know get me out of a job. So in a same
thing organizations our programs model that
philosophy. Um, after mindful- it is very
important to become a more mindful organization,
because what happens in a mindful organizations
is there's a lot natural empathy develops,
natural listening develops, uh, natural um,
natural self-awareness, you know. Uh, when
we do, emotional intelligence surveys for
leaders, one of the prime competencies of
course, is self-awareness. And there is, we
have lots of data showing that that self-awareness
does develop, empathy does develop, through
mindfulness practice and you know, the right
kind of mindfulness practice. So, um, I'm
all for it, I think it, you're in a great
organization, right here that's uh, cutting
edge and it's just really, really a thrill
to have a, a shared mindset around the these
ideas. I just really feel very honored. So
I want to thank you for that. Thank all the
Google-ites for that . Yeah. Question? Come
on, one more? Yeah.
>>Male #4: [inaudible] but from like a spiritual
perspective, is there like one thing you'd
recommend starting today or tomorrow to become
more spiritual? [inaudible]
>>Karuna: The question was is there one thing
on a individual level that we could do to
just start the process of becoming more aware.
Uh, yes, I there is there is a requirement
for this and I'm not going to pull any, what's
that expression? Pull any punches. You have,
we have to be engaged in some kind of mind
training, ok. Which means we have to begin
to turn our uh, the default automatic approach
around. The way to do that is we have to do
it, we have to at least have some sort of,
when I say mind training, it doesn't have
to just be meditation, but it has to be something
that really trains me, and eventually meditation.
Because what do you call meditation, whatever
you like to call it, I like to call it mind
training. So the first thing to do, what I
would suggest people do, if they're just going
to start, is do that ABCD method that I talked
about. Do it at your desk or wherever you
work and watch. The only thing we need to
do, well not the only thing, but the first
thing and the thing we do from beginning middle
to end is to be curious and so what you're
doing is I going to watch my mind like I'd
watch the Olympics. Ok, you know in the Olympics
they tell how "Now here's how he does"
they go into all the dialog and explanation.
We want that stuff. But we don't we just watch.
And so it's more like, just become a learner.
And your, your what you're learning is your
mind. So you have to, it's just about watching
it right now and to watch it you have to quiet
it. In other words, if we just sit, we don't
have time but if we just sit and said everyone
watch your mind. How long do you think you'd
be watching your mind? Anybody have anything?
>>Female Announcer: A few seconds.
>>Karuna: It's a few seconds! Is that, I think
that that's what's the word for me, someone
help me with the adjective, that's not a that's
pathetic, uh, hah?
>>Audience members: Preposterous
>>Karuna: Preposterous! That's perfect. That's
preposterous! We've had this mind for twenty,
thirty, forty, fifty whatever years and we
can't watch it for more than a few seconds?
But we can develop that. So focus, so if when
the first thing you do is focus on the breath,
do the counting that I was talking about and
if you can do that and you bring your mind
back, you notice the distractions, that's
all you need to do in the beginning. 'Cause
there's ABCD, I didn't tell you the D. The
D is notice distractions. There's also an
E, it comes later. [Laughter] Yeah, part two.
Ok? So I am good? Well good. Ok, I think that's
it. Thank you very much. Thank you.
[applause]